hey here's some good news we are now
sort of I would I'm saying we're at 95%
on the new studio Pat are you sort of in
line with my assessment there well you
said that recently and we were nowhere
near close to 95% we were perhaps 30% so
I don't trust your judgment on this
unfortunately okay good well so anyway
let's edit out what Pat's opinion is on
this and I'll just come back to me I am
now because we are doing so great with
the new studio I am ready to go back to
some of the fun things that we were
thinking of doing on the show and one of
them I want to go back to is this idea
of a David Pakman show bingo card which
was in a few different sub reddit
threads at david pakman.com slash read
it there was a sort of group of proposed
elements for a David Pakman show bingo
card where people could play along and
these are all things that I say
frequently on the show we Pat is now
part of the possible bingo card things
that happen on the show so I want to
refocus on actually getting this bingo
card thing done so let me remind you I
actually printed out you could hear the
paper which makes it real just like on
the Rush Limbaugh Show where he he makes
paper noises so you know that it's it's
really all backed by paper here are some
of the things people suggested it would
be great to consolidate these maybe in
one reddit thread email me if you have
other ideas but here are some funny
things that could be on a David Pakman
show bingo card and a lot of these
padded David asks the caller are we on
speaker or Bluetooth that happens all
the time
also another possibility would be caller
actually is on speakerphone or Bluetooth
we might actually need both of those Pat
because both happen very frequently yeah
it's actually a frequent occurrence
though maybe too frequent for bingo that
happens once every month call second at
least yeah if it's happening every week
it's not really a good thing okay David
sang quite frankly that happens David
punching the mic that's also one that is
probably only every couple of weeks so
that could be a good one David chuckles
or says right over the audio of a news
clip that's playing yeah people write in
some people write to me Pat saying they
like that you can sometimes hear my
reaction
in real-time to the video clips other
people say that I'm just interfering
with them just hearing the clip I don't
know it seems the audience is kind of
split I like it I think it adds a little
bit of something extra to the video clip
people can see that video clip on its
own if they want to but if they want to
see our take on it they got to hear the
chuckling they got to hear the right
that's been my view but Who am I to tell
the audience what it is they should want
caller is exercising or in a noisy area
during the [ __ ] yes that is a problem
we've dealt with David asks caller what
would it take to change your mind yet
that I I've adopted the fees the deficit
D fees I've adopted the de feasibility
question with callers when they call in
with something outrageous and it's clear
that they're not really open to having
their mind changed and so I asked them
what evidence if I had it would change
your mind and that does sometimes open
interesting lines of communication I
think that that's a great one oh I love
it too especially because when you say
that there is no evidence that could
change your mind that means that your
beliefs are not rooted in evidence and
that's kind of a conversation ender
right there absolutely absolutely
david says sabotage but pronounces it
sabotage and references William Shatner
I do say that David says with peace and
love there's a lot of these david says
ones which i think they need to be it
needs to be a mix of phrases but also
things that happen so i don't know that
we can do all of these but people want
with peace and love on the bingo card
when I call something a gong show when I
say that something is abortive or use
the word depraved or reference
fetishists of any kind like a
constitutional fetishist or a second
amendment fetishist or whatever david
uses the story segue hey this is sort of
weird you know it's funny about that I
did that last story I introduced the
last story about Trump and cereal by
saying hey this is sort of weird
sometimes I don't know how to transition
from stories that are very different and
hey this is sort of weird is kind of a
natural way to me the other thing you do
is desperate attempts at alliteration
like you'll introduce a story by talking
about Donald Trump's the
rest deranged depraved
National Security Adviser whatever else
it is yeah I remember doing it with that
woman from what was that woman's name
it's she's so irrelevant a Kim Davis I
think it was who was refusing gay
marriage licenses to people I would
interview I would introduce her as
something like completely corrupt
Kentucky County Clerk Kim Davis but it
was like way more I don't even remember
what the other one she likes her
re-election bid she was a victim of the
blue wave I saw that I saw that I saw
that David using the term apoplectic
David says but you might be saying hold
on a second David yeah that's how I
broach when I want to sort of give what
a right wing argument might be and then
take it down I will sometimes broach it
by saying now you might be saying hold
on a second David and then I kind of go
go forward I recognize I do that and
here's a pat one pat says I'm gonna push
back a little bit on this one which is a
phrase that you do sometimes use pat
when you are sort of like announcing to
me and to the world that you are going
to be disagreeing with my perspective I
think that that is one that should be on
there I'm gonna push back a little bit
on this one yeah I like that because
whenever my counter arguments fall apart
I can just act as if it wasn't really my
position and that I was just trying to
play it so that's how I prevent that
definitely does brilliant so send me
your thoughts on these send me thoughts
for others the next layer that we need
to figure out after we figure out what's
included in the David Pakman show bingo
card is what do you win if you win David
Pakman show bingo and the other thing is
I am looking into having a sound board
for the show and so like now that I
sometimes will say please vote or please
sign up it would be great if I was able
to play what the source of that is which
is like Jeb Bush saying please clap when
he made an applause line at a speech and
nobody clapped so what would be on an
ideal david pakman show sound board like
would the eggman be on it saying Shalom
brother which is how he signs off from
his voicemails what would be on the
sound board anyway let's um let's work
on that and we're gonna get all of that
together
today's program sponsored in part by
blinkers comm slash Pakman I've talked
about blinkers before it's this awesome
app that I've been using for several
months now and what it does is take the
best and most critically acclaimed
non-fiction books and condenses them
into 15-minute audiobooks that you can
listen to in one sitting you could
listen to ten books in an afternoon I
know that many in our audience want to
expand their horizons and learn more
about all sorts of different topics but
we're mostly limited by time to some
degree I know I'm not able to read all
of the books that I want simply because
I've got other stuff going on and that's
why blink is - such a great tool you can
absorb the most important information
and insights from the book in one
sitting and our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink accom
slash Pakman if you're watching on
youtube click the link in the video
description and after that free trial if
you like blinka stand i think you are
going to like it
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month go to be li NK is t.com
slash PA k ma n